moteur
contre cancer
c'était il y a cinq ans, on m'a diagnostiqué un
cancer en phase terminale, ce qu'elle a fait était
un mensonge tellement flagrant et à une telle
échelle, acceptez-vous que vous soyez un
menteur pathologique non
[Musique]
noches est [
Musique]
bianore
par le  La fois où je suis arrivé à
regarder Belle Gibson, je
pensais certainement qu'il s'agissait
potentiellement d'une sorte de cas de fraude. Eh bien,
Gibson
est étranger. L'
une des choses qui m'a motivé à
faire ces histoires au début était
que mon  ma femme avait un cancer, j'en savais assez
sur le cancer à ce moment-là pour savoir qu'il
serait très improbable qu'elle
ait survécu, que cette tumeur au cerveau
Gibson est
El Amor,
elle avait déjà paru dans
certains magazines féminins dont elle avait fait
la couverture  une sorte de
magazine Lifestyle ici, elle avait reçu un
prix par l'une des applications de magazines féminins
[Musique] qui
valait la peine de se développer et j'ai mis tout ce
que je savais tout au long de mon parcours avec la
nutrition contre le cancer et le bien-être, je
l'ai mis sur l'appareil le plus accessible
possible  applications
J'étais juste étonné,
comme si cela n'avait aucun sens, cette
femme a été partout dans les médias,
personne ne semble avoir vérifié les faits
sur son histoire
lorsque je suis allé chercher en ligne
tout ce qu'elle avait fait sur les
réseaux sociaux plus longtemps  il y a plus de deux ans avait
complètement disparu et il
me semblait qu'elle avait effacé son historique
jusqu'au moment où elle a lancé l'
entreprise et cela m'a fait vraiment
soupçonner que tout le garde-manger était sa
marque, vous savez, elle avait une société qui
était enregistrée et  J'ai vérifié les
registres de l'entreprise et
la date de naissance qu'elle avait indiquée sur
ce formulaire de candidature officiel était
complètement différente de l'âge
qu'elle avait dit aux gens, vous savez,
elle avait dit aux gens qu'elle avait trois ans.
ans de plus qu'elle ne l'était en réalité,
je me suis dit que la chose que je
devais faire était de m'asseoir avec elle
et de lui demander de me raconter son histoire officiellement,
alors je suis allé la rencontrer et nous nous sommes assis dans
ce café à Melbourne.  où elle vivait
et je l'ai interviewée pendant environ une heure
et c'était juste l'une des interviews les plus étranges que
j'ai jamais faites, elle a
soudainement commencé à
se retirer de certaines des choses qu'elle
avait dites et elle a essayé de commencer à
raconter  moi, tu sais qu'elle ne savait pas
vraiment si elle avait cinq cancers
après tout
étrangers
et donc elle a inventé cette nouvelle histoire
selon laquelle ce médecin l'avait
mal diagnostiquée et maintenant elle a réalisé
qu'elle n'aurait peut-être pas tous ces
cancers après tout
quand  Je lui ai demandé qui était le médecin, tu
sais, elle ne pouvait pas me donner son nom,
tout est devenu très vague à ce
moment-là,
j'ai vécu pendant des années avec la peur de
mourir
et c'est horrible,
euh,
comment pouvons-nous croire tout ce que tu dis maintenant
quand tu  J'ai touché le fond, il n'y a
qu'une opportunité d'être honnête, de
guérir et de m'excuser
et je suis ici pour le faire.
Elle avait deux cent mille adeptes
du monde entier et ils
la traitaient comme Jésus, vous
savez, comme ils l'avaient fait.  Je pensais qu'elle était
ce genre d'idole miraculeuse,
euh, qu'ils pouvaient me suivre,
ce qu'elle a fait était un mensonge si flagrant et
à une telle échelle et cela a vraiment
eu un impact profond sur ses partisans,
ils ont été choqués, alors sa réputation
était tellement trash
c'est qu'elle
n'a jamais payé cette amende et,
en gros, elle n'a jamais vraiment été
punie financièrement,
sauf que bien sûr, elle a perdu
toute son entreprise.
Justice
[Musique] est
affectée
ouais, je pense que c'est une personne très troublée, il
est très probable qu'elle ait
une sorte de trouble de la personnalité  d'
une manière ou d'une autre, il y
a une communauté éthiopienne à
Melbourne où elle vit et elle a
commencé à se présenter à leurs
réunions communautaires habillée de façon traditionnelle,
presque comme un hijab comme un
foulard. Je pense que le plus grand pouvoir
que nous avons est que nous avons la chance de
vivre dans  la diaspora en ce moment,
donc notre voix est beaucoup plus grande et a
plus de pouvoir que nos frères
et sœurs opprimés, ils n'avaient aucune idée de qui elle était
et ils l'ont en quelque sorte embrassée, puis
ils ont découvert qui elle était, combien de
nos gens sont en prison
étrangère
[Musique]